on Monday the supposedly bipartisan
women's March tweeted out a happy
birthday message to an actual
honest-to-goodness terrorist Assata
Shakur there's an image of her notices
it's a drawing though Assata Shakur
against the pink and purple background
and above her head are the words a
woman's place is in the struggle it says
happy birthday to the revolutionary
Assata Shakur today sign of resistance
in Asada's honor is by Maloney espanha
the tweet came complete with a picture
of Shakur with the slogan is in the
struggle pasted at the top in May 1973
Shakur was wounded in a shootout with
state troopers on the New Jersey
Turnpike one trooper was killed
execution-style she was convicted of the
murder and then sentence to life in
prison
she'd also participate in a bunch of
bank robberies apparently in 1979 she
escaped from prison and then finally
fled to Cuba
where she's been living she is still on
the FBI most wanted terrorist list
there's a two million dollar reward on
her head as David French points out in
national review all told from 1970 to
1980 for the be la the Black Liberation
Army was responsible for four bombings
for hijacking thirty-two violent armed
confrontations in the US 16 of those
involved confrontations with law
enforcement officers who were killed in
other words by every reasonable
contemporary definition of terrorism
Shakur was a violent terrorist who
belonged to a violent terrorist
organization now Shakur has become a
hero to leftist because she rejects the
morality of Western civilization she was
a member of that Black Liberation Army a
more violent splinter from the Black
Panther Party in Cuba she wrote a trite
autobiography in which she made claims
like this quote take hollows bandits yet
every time most black people pick up our
paychecks we are being robbed every time
we walk into a store in our neighborhood
we are being held up and every time we
pay our rent the landlord sticks a gun
into our ribs the rulers of this country
and their flunkies have committed some
of the most brutal vicious crimes in
history they are the bandits they are
the murderers and they should be treated
as such
this is pretty vile stuff but it stirred
by the far-left brought up on Howard
Zinn and trained to see America as the
enemy
no wonder Linda Sarsour is welcomed with
open arms by the women's March by the
way the women's March is now written a
full explanation of their happy birthday
message it is not helpful they tweeted
women's March is a non-violent movement
we have never and will never use
violence to achieve our goals the far
right is threatened by our movement and
by our solidarity with other movements
our power your success scares the far
right they continue to try to divide us
today's attacks on Assata Shakur the
latest example here's a brief refresher
on who Assata Shakur is and why we can
a feminist figure Assata Shakur is a
civil rights leader who used her
leadership position to challenge sexism
within the black liberation movement her
resistance tactics were different from
ours that does not mean that we do not
respect her anti-sexism work I look
forward to the women's March depending
on Salman bin Laden on anti Islamophobia
grounds i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show all righty so everything is
awful yeah everything's pretty terrible
so we will talk about why everything is
so terrible in just a second but it's
also in every horror is a little bit of
sick sad hilarity as there is today so
we'll get into all that but first on
that bright note I want to thank our
sponsors over at Boleyn branch so
perhaps you woke up and saw the news and
wanted to go back to sleep I know that I
did well that means that I go back to
sleep on my magical unbelievably great
bull and branch cheeks so these are the
best sheets there are these sheets are
super comfortable they are breathable
they are so good that I literally will
not sleep on other sheets in my home we
have thrown away all of our other sheets
or given them away and the reason is
that bolt and branch is twice the
quality of other sheets for about half
the price you can try them for 30 nights
and see for yourself they're 100%
organic cotton they will get you the
best sleep of your life I am not good at
sleeping it is one of my poorer
qualities is being good at sleep I'm not
good at it but Boleyn branch makes sure
that I get the sleep that I need is bol
el and branch compromised Ben right now
if you do that you get $50 off your
first set of sheets plus free shipping
when you use that promo code Ben bull
and branch comm today $50 off plus free
shipping right now bull and branch calm
and use that promo code then again they
are the best sheets there are I mean
I've gone out and bought a bunch of sets
for myself for family members they're
that good Boleyn branch calm and use
that promo code Ben's that they know
that we saw you okay so the big news of
the day is of course that Trump care is
dead in the Senate so Trump care was
this crappy Obamacare replacement bill
that was really Obamacare 2.0 it did a
couple of good things that restructured
Medicaid so instead of it being just a
need-based program or the federal
government signs an open-ended check to
a bunch of different states
it actually was a grant based program
where they were going to give block
grants to the states it didn't cut
Medicaid it cut
it cut the rate of growth in Medicaid
funding so if Obamacare had Medicaid
funding going like this then Trump care
had Obamacare funding for Medicaid going
like that right leveling off after 2020
that was one of the good aspects of it
the other good aspect of it was it cut a
few of the taxes it didn't really do
much to relieve the Obama care
regulations and this was the problem
Obamacare is the regulations Obamacare
is forcing the insurance companies to
offer a bunch of things on their plan
now Mike Lee and Ted Cruz had come up
with an amendment that would have
allowed insurance companies to actually
provide plans outside of the Obamacare
regulations but when Mitch McConnell put
it back in the bill the provision did
not include that it was it was it said
that you could get out of some of the
regulations but then you were still
subject to the Obamacare Marketplace
exchanges which means that it
artificially jacks up the prices for
young healthy people who want to buy
skimpier versions of health insurance
yesterday Mike Lee and Jerry Moran who
is the senator from Kansas they both
came out and they said that they are not
going to back the bill so Moran
explained we should not put our stamp of
approval on bad policy furthermore if we
leave the federal government in control
of everyday healthcare decisions it is
more likely that our health care system
will devolve into single-payer which
will require a massive federal spending
increase li said in addition to not
repealing all of the Obamacare taxes it
doesn't go far enough in lowering
premiums for middle-class families nor
does it create enough free space for the
most costly from the most costly
Obamacare regulations so that meant that
there were four senators now who are not
going to vote to advance the house bill
with the tenant changes that be Rand
Paul whose all along said this is not a
free-market version of a bill I'm not
voting for it Susan Collins from Maine
who says it's not Obamacare so I'm not
voting for it she's basically a Democrat
and then you have jerry moran and mike
lee said they're not going to vote for
it but less anyone think that these four
are really the only obstacle the fact is
that there were supposedly eight to ten
other senators who really tentative on
it and that's because the thing had a
twenty percent approval rating it was
basically keeping a lot of the worst
aspects of obamacare and getting rid of
the funding mechanism which was all the
taxes under obamacare and increasing
subsidies in certain areas so that was
it wasn't a great plan it had a lot of
holes in it avec roy who loved the plan
he liked it because of the Medicaid
reform but he can do Medicaid reform
through other means you don't have to do
Medicaid reform as part of the health
care reform bill they are not quite the
same thing so this bill is dead
so yesterday started
on a bizarre note ok this was supposed
to be made in America week for the Trump
White House and president Trump leads
off yesterday by sitting in a fire truck
which of course led to one thousand
terrible headlines for him tonight
understand the roadblocks are foremost
meant having the vice president
president of the United States dancing
around getting a fire
the party had from a different kind of
trunk now we have arrived expire from
what president creating a fire in their
little fire trucks my trees she got in
the driver's seat
doing the same thing doing things the
President must constantly first undress
and then there's like this new phase I
did it again he's not the only President
to do stupid photo ops but this is a
really dumb photo op it's a particularly
dumb photo op when he's in a fire truck
at the wheel of the fire truck and
literally a mile away his Trump care
bill is on fire that actually is not a
good look he then came out yesterday and
John McCain one of the things that
helped kill this was John McCain was
probably going to vote in favor of the
Trump care bill or at least that was the
rumor and then he got sick and had to
have a surgery and so Trump yesterday he
was touting John McCain and saying that
he needed his vote we hope John McCain
gets better very soon because we miss
him he's a crusty voice in Washington
plus we need his vote okay that was true
but it wasn't enough okay so Mike Lee
comes out he explains why exactly hidden
vote for this thing and he said this is
not a full repeal of Obamacare we
promise we're going to fully repeal
Obamacare and this isn't it I have made
very clear from the outset of this
discussion that what the American people
asked for what they expected when they
elected Republicans to the house to the
Senate and of the White House was a full
repeal of Obamacare that's what we ought
to be doing no I'm not saying it's
either perfection or nothing but I am
saying you've got to show me what this
really does to undo Obamacare is deadly
consequences for the forgotten man and
the forgotten woman of America I don't
see that in this bill what I do see is
that we've walked away steadily from all
kinds of promises this bill no longer
repeals all of our cares taxes I think
that's troubling this bill no longer
release people of some of the most
significant burdens regulatory speaking
from Obamacare that have made the cost
of health care go sky-high and we can do
better
but the American people have to demand
it okay so I agree with everything that
you heard Mike Lee just say so the
question
who is to blame for all of this because
now Trump care has gone down we're going
to explain what's coming next after
Trump care has gone down because now
Senator McConnell says that he wants to
bring a full repeal bill to the floor of
the Senate we'll explain whether that
happens or not but who is to blame for
all of this so you're seeing people like
President Trump blames and a
conservatives will say it's a few
senators really stop this thing he said
that Laura Ingraham came out today and
she says well I guess the Trump is going
to have to work with the Democrats now
so no no no no everyone know everyone's
stupid okay so here is who to who is to
blame for this number one Senate
moderates who lied when they said they
were going to support Obamacare repeal
and they demonstrated that they lied
when they said this okay as I say Mitch
McConnell says that now he's going to
bring to the floor some sort of repeal
bill he can he used the House bill that
was passed as a basically the vehicle
for a full repeal and the repeal would
go into effect in two years so it'd
basically be a ticking time bomb and
then Republicans would have two years to
get their act together and come up with
some correctives
for when the time bomb goes off after
the elections right so it's actually a
relatively smart play by McConnell but
it also holds a bunch of Republicans
feet to the fire trying to demonstrate
who exactly was willing to vote for
repeal and who is not already within 15
minutes of him announcing this already
this morning there were three
Republicans who said they would not vote
for simple repeal remember for seven
years we have heard nothing from the
Republican Party but we need to repeal
Obamacare not repeal and replace repeal
and replace as a formulation pursued by
Trump okay it was if it was a
formulation pursued by moderate
Republicans but they all said they were
going to repeal and the the proof is in
the pudding okay Rob Portman today the
senator from Ohio he voted for a simple
repeal bill in 2015 when Barack Obama
was president today Mitch McConnell said
we want to pass a simple repeal bill the
exact same repeal bill we voted for in
2015 and Senator Rob Portman who is just
a weak tea senator from Ohio here's what
he had to say about it so I have to look
and see what the so-called repeal bill
entails but it is a bill that simply
repeals I believe that will add the more
uncertainty and the potential for you
know Iowans to pay even higher premiums
higher deductibles so what to see
obviously we would look for a CBO
analysis of that to see
involves in terms of it's not just
premiums inductive bulls but coverage so
you know I'll take a look at it I'm
concerned about something that would
simply repeal and its impact on costs
and choices in health care okay so there
you have it he says that he is not going
to vote for a simple repeal even though
he did so in 2015
showing that Republicans are damn liars
okay they are liars they say this kind
of stuff and they don't mean it one iota
or at least many of them don't and when
they do minute like Mike Lee they get
ripped up and down by a bunch of
establishment lackeys and hacks who say
that it's Mike Lee's fault that
Obamacare is still on the books
basically here was the deal the GOP made
they said hey let's repeal Obamacare and
everyone yeah that sounds awesome and
they said how about if we don't repeal
Obamacare but we say we did and then
conservatives went no let's not do that
and then the GOP turned around they said
it's conservatives fault that Obamacare
is staying see we told you it's all
their fault they're unrealistic okay Rob
Portman voted in 2015 that he would vote
for repeal he said today that he
probably will not Shelley Moore Capito
who voted for exactly the same bill in
2015 said today as I have said before I
did not come to Washington to hurt
people for months I have expressed
reservations about the direction of the
bill to repeal and replace Obamacare I
cannot vote for appeal Obamacare without
a replacement plan that addresses my
concerns and the needs of West
Virginians in other words repeal and
replace was just an excuse for keep
Obamacare that's what we had suspected
all along Mitch McConnell is complicit
in this he said while he was doing this
bill that even the Medicaid reforms that
everybody really loved he said that
those Medicaid reforms would never
materialize that's what he told the
moderates it was not enough to get susan
collins on board anyway okay so all of
these people are totally full of it
which means that the new Republican
program is basically let's just complain
about Democrats but when we have power
we won't do anything here's Mitch
McConnell lamenting the Democrats who
are who are saying that they're happy
that this thing went down in flames
imagine many Democrats were celebrating
last night
I hope they consider what they are
celebrating the American people are
hurting they need relief and it's
regretful that our Democratic colleagues
decided early on that they did not want
to engage with us seriously in the
process to deliver relief okay so again
you know
he can say all he wants here but he's
the guy in charge he's the guy in charge
and this is on Senator McConnell for not
getting it together so does he have a
fractious Republican caucus of course
his a fractious Republican caucus does
he have a bunch of people on the Left
who don't want to vote for Obamacare
repeal yes does um bunch of people on
the right who don't want to vote for
anything soft yes but his job to get
those things together if he can't then
he shouldn't be in charge of the Senate
end of story okay
there's someone else to blame in all of
this too and I know that we're never
allowed to blame President Trump for
anything I know that we have to play
footsie around president Trump to treat
him like he's a small child and he has
to be guarded from the vicissitudes of
life
the fact is president Trump botched this
okay he botched this in three separate
ways he botched it repeatedly now I want
to know that you'll just notice all over
them be honest with you today okay it's
difficult to be honest to people who
listen we all want Trump to succeed I
want Trump to succeed as a conservative
I want him to do conservative things
today if Trump were to push for repeal
and get repeal I would be in the front
row cheering I put on a damn Magna hat
when he put when he picked Judge gorsek
so this is not about ire at President
Trump for anything except for he's not
doing his job okay and I know everybody
has to go out of their way to praise
Trump because Trump's ego requires the
praise all the time but the fact is that
praising Trump in getting the job done
okay Mike Pence said Trump is really
engaged in the process no he's not he
was in a fire truck while this thing was
going down in flames okay there are
three different ways that Trump screwed
this thing up okay way number one during
the election cycle he said over and over
1 bajillion times that he wanted to
repeal Obamacare he then added no one
would go uncovered you cannot say those
two things simultaneously that meant
that when he was elected he did not have
a clear mandate to repeal Obamacare so
that was mistake number one he spends
his entire election cycle saying
Obamacare has to go but I'd like to
replace it with something that gives
more coverage in other words Obamacare
is not single-payer enough right that's
actually what he was saying during the
election cycle okay then after he gets
an office he has an opportunity he has
100 percent approval rating among
Republicans right everybody in the
Senate is afraid of him what if he had
come out day one and said Obamacare
repeal that's it okay we'll figure out
the replacement later we got to get this
done fast before time runs out Obamacare
repeal now presidents had Cruz president
Rubio I think but President Cruz
certainly would have done that right he
would have exerted pressure right that's
what Trump would have done he didn't do
that
instead he sat back he let Mitch
McConnell take the reins
he let Paul Ryan take the reins because
Trump was not engaged because Trump
doesn't care about isn't because Trump
doesn't even know his own policy and
because Trump doesn't even know what's
in the bill if you ask from what's in
this bill he would not be able to tell
you which is why today President Trump
offered in 12 hours three different
strategies for what should happen after
the death of this bill he tweeted
Republicans should just repeal failing
Obamacare now and work on a new health
care plan that will start from a clean
slate Devens will join in
no they won't this is delusional okay
Democrats are not going to work with
President Trump his second proposal was
blame Republicans he said we were let
down by all of the Democrats and a few
Republicans most Republicans were loyal
terrific and worked really hard we will
return as I have always said let
Obamacare fail and then come together
and do a great health care plan stay
tuned and literally within hours of him
saying repeal and then figure it out
Democrats he's now saying don't repeal
let it fail and then figure it out with
Democrats okay all of this confusion
does not allow you to exert pressure on
your own members of Congress the
president has a job here the president's
job here is actually pretty clear if
you're in Congress let me start from the
Congressional perspective if you're in
Congress you're running for Senate you
have two things you have to do to win a
Senate seat first just win a primary and
then you have to win in general winning
a general generally requires you not to
do anything controversial if you do
something controversial you give
material to your opponent so if you're a
senator you have an actual stake in not
doing things because then your opponent
can't claim that you're doing anything
really terrible right if you vote for a
bill with 20% approval as this bill had
and then Democrats crap all over you
then you could lose a general election
right so your interest is in doing
nothing so what keeps you voting for
unpopular bills and sticking inline with
the party pressure from the party right
the threat of defunding the threat of
primaries President Trump has only
threatened to primary one Republican
senator since the election jeff flake of
arizona okay that has nothing to do with
obamacare it has to do if he doesn't
like senator flake right he's not
exerting pressure he's not doing what
the White House has to do what if Trump
were on the phone with all of these
wavering senators day in and day out
saying listen I will primary you I will
come to your state and I will undercut
support for you
I will remove funding I will let you
flail out there I will rip you by name
publicly if you do this but that's not
what Trump was doing Trump was busy
playing firetruck and he was busy
tweeting things okay so that is screw up
number three right so screw up number
one was his pitch screw up number two
was he didn't actually embrace Obamacare
appeal in the first place when he became
president and screw up number three is
that he has completely abdicated
responsibility for this even while
people are praising him for his
engagement he has not been engaged if he
were engaged then maybe it changes the
math so again it's not all on Trump but
to pretend that Trump is not involved at
all in this is really silly okay it's
from care it's a signature piece of
legislation Obama was heavily involved
in pushing his signature piece of
legislation I don't think that we should
expect anything less from President
Trump it just doesn't make a lot of
sense to me in any case but the media of
course are in full Trump defense mode at
least on the right because it's more
important to please Trump than it is to
actually push good policy which is one
of my key criticisms here okay for
fellow conservatives Trump can be all
the things you want him to be you can
love him dearly you can hope that he
does really well he needs to fulfill
what you said he was going to fulfill
and what he said to you he was going to
fulfill but watch Fox and Friends read
Fox and Friends is basically the Trump
show and here is them going after the
Senators wouldn't vote for this original
bill you have Rand Paul extreme
conservatives slash libertarian Ted Cruz
I'm going to get my hands dirty make
this work somehow they got moderates
like Senator Portman listen to his
governor and you have senator Collins
who said I got some huge blowback when I
went back so these people are being
through their school just not true to
their party and maybe not true to their
country the president said before this
didn't before he knew that these two he
had these two defectors reportedly
according to Politico he goes if the
Senate Republicans don't get this thing
done they'll look like dopes do they
look like dopes he's right it's not a
question being true to your party or
true to your country it's a question
being true to your word they should not
have elevated the issue for eight years
among Republicans saying first thing two
thoughts repeal and replace if they
weren't capable of doing okay again all
of this they're going to toss all this
is defeated McConnell and Ryan deserve a
heavy dose of blame both of them the
Congress deserves a heavy dose of lame
Trump does not get off scot-free he is
the president of you
out of state he's grown with the bully
pulpit he's won with 82 percent approval
rating among Republicans today despite
his low approval ratings generally
Republicans still love the guy
he has leverage he didn't use that
leverage it is that simple okay before I
go any further and talk about what comes
next I first want to say thank you to
our sponsors over at mbm T so my watch
they wear every single day is an M VMT
watch it is a fantastic-looking watch
but they are not just making watches
anymore they are now making sunglasses
which is awesome so I have a brand new
pair of sunglasses I'll bring them in
next time but they have just the classic
looking minimalist in design they start
to 70 bucks with the option to upgrade
to polarize a designer brand will run
you $200 on a pair of sunglasses these
are high-quality premium acetate frames
no cheap plastic they are fantastic go
over to M DMT calm movement calm M VMT
calm / capiro and you get 15% off with
free shipping and free returns
they've already revolutionized the watch
industry now that revolutionising the
sunglasses industry as well just
great-looking sunglasses MVM t.com /
shapiro again they're inexpensive and
they are durable and they are fantastic
they're designer quality but not as
designer prices M VMT calm / appear you
get 15% off your order today the
sunglasses are great get the watch and
the sunglass you look like a million
bucks it really is terrific stuff okay
so let's get back to what exactly
happens from here so as I say the first
proposal was let's just repeal Obamacare
wholesale and a bunch of moderate
senators said no we're not going to do
that and then the proposal is okay we'll
let Obamacare fail and then we'll come
back to the table the problem with this
is that they need the tax increase that
they need the the revenue that was saved
through Obamacare cuts in order to pass
tax reform so it's not just that
Obamacare repeal went down if the tax
reform is now in danger remember
everything has to be passed with a fifty
one-vote reconciliation rule that means
the CBO has to score everything is
revenue neutral meaning that you can't
lose money on it you can't create more
debt more deficit in order to pass a
bill what that means is that all of the
savings that are going to have from the
Obamacare repeal they were originally
going to apply to tax reform if they
don't get the repeal they don't get the
tax reform and the entire legislative
agenda is sung plus the issue isn't
going away Obamacare continues to
devolve into disaster and now the
Republicans have
put their grubby mitts on it it's going
to be very difficult for them to remove
their stink from it right it looks like
they tried to fix it and I fail and so
now Democrats are going to say listen
they tried to fix it and fail they stink
put us in charge and they're going to
have a point especially after
Republicans tried to push a Democrat
light program all of this is about us
and it demonstrates and in politics if
you do not campaign on a program and if
you are not clever enough to campaign on
other things and then implement a
program with the full weight of your
authority you are going to be in in
serious political trouble plus you're
not going to get anything done and so
the question is going to be come here
can you pressure your Republican
representatives and the president to do
the right thing and so I'm going to do
something I never do on this program
okay here are the phone numbers for
Senators Portman capito and Collins
these are there these are their Senate
office phone numbers I want people to
call and flood their offices okay
senator rob portman today the senator
from Ohio he says he will not vote for
pure repeal his number is to zero to two
to four 33 53 that is his Senate office
phone number I never do this - OH - to -
for 33 53 senator Shelley Moore Capito
from West Virginia her number is 202 2
to 4 64 72 202 - to 464 72 and senator
Susan Collins for whatever that it will
do is 202 2 to 4 25:23 they all deserve
to have their secretaries have a
miserable day on the phones because they
spent seven years lying to you seven
full years lying to you and and Trump
better figure something out quick care
because he's the president okay his
agenda that's on the line and maybe it
doesn't matter maybe we've all become
satisfied with tweeting CNN memes and
all that and it's fun but you know if
you actually wanna get something done
it's going to actually have to get done
at a certain point here okay
as we continue we're going to move over
to daily wire right now but I still want
to talk about a bunch of things
including whether the polls actually
matter to President Trump is he immune
to - pull
it's a polling a little bit more Russia
fallout plus things I like things I hate
will deconstruct the culture but for
they are going to have to go over to
Daley wire comm so for those who don't
know this is a video show as well you
can watch it the first 15 minutes on
Facebook but if you want to watch the
entire thing then you need to go over to
Daley wire right now and subscribe for
$9.99 a month then you can get the full
subscription over a daily wire they can
do access to the show live it gets you
access to the mailbag which we do on
Fridays you get to
at the end of Clayton's show which is
great you should listen to it I'm sure
he'll disagree with me today so if you
want a lighter take then go over to
Clayton's show today and you can get the
subscription for his show and for
Michael Moses new show god help us
that's coming out pretty soon so you can
check that out for $99 a year
you can get the annual subscription
which is even better than that because
not only do you get all of the appli
mention things you also get this
unbelievable magnificent incomparable
mug I mean it's just fantastic this
tumbler right here that says upon it
left this tears hot or cold in silver
etching just unbelievably magnificent
dishwasher safe makes julienne fries
just awesome in every conceivable way
this left this year this lets the stairs
tumbler you will enjoy it and and you
can go over and get the annual
subscription for it right now so go over
there and check it out or listen later
at iTunes or SoundCloud and when you do
that make sure that you leave us a
review we always appreciate it
we are the largest conservative podcast
in the nation
[Music]
already so the question that there are
two questions here one is what do we
care about and the two and question
number two is is there gonna be electron
fallout so what do we care about
question is something that I've now been
asking for months okay do we care more
about the we piss off the left routine
or do we care more about pushing policy
now there are certain people who say
that the pissing off the left routine is
part of the pushing policy routine I'd
be warmer to that argument if we were
actually pushing policy but clearly that
didn't work so the question now is is
not what do we care about because I
think that we care about what we care
about what is going to get done is
what's going to get done
the bigger question right now is is
there going to be a leopard will fall
out now it doesn't matter if there's
electoral fallout if we don't pass
anything I'm not sure that there is but
right now the polls are not good for
president Trump but there is an open
question about the polls which is do
they even matter do the polls even
matter with matter with regard to
President Trump now I'm at the point
where there are certain polls that I
generally trust in there certain polls
that I do not so I think the Trump is
more popular than he is unpopular no do
I think that some of the polls that are
more ridiculous are true no so for
example there was a poll from Public
Policy Polling yesterday it said only
45% of Republicans think the Donald
Trump jr. met with the Russians okay
Donald Trump jr. admitted to meeting
with the Russians so he met with the
Russians okay this is not under dispute
but everybody on the Left had what was
just demonstrates how all of the
Republicans believe stupid things know
what that question was questioning and
what people were answering was not did
Donald Trump jr. meet with the Russians
do you care if Donald Trump jr. met with
the Russians and only 45% of Republicans
said yes again Republicans are smart
enough to read the signals from the
polls so when someone from ABC News
calls up and says we have a poll
question for you
Republicans aren't just hearing the poll
question they are hearing the subtext of
the poll question and they're answering
the subtext so if they're asked do you
think the Donald Trump jr. did something
wrong on the Russia stuff what they are
hearing is do you think that Donald
Trump colluded with the Russian
government and so Republicans will say
no Republicans are answering the
questions they think are being asked and
in reality are actually being asked by
the media so I think that a lot of the
people who are being pulled on the right
side of the aisle have gotten too smart
for the pollsters in other words when
polls when pollsters call them up they
are giving them answers that are
designed to go right to the subtext so
instead of them saying yes Donald Trump
jr. met with the Russians but I don't
think it matters instead they say he
didn't meet with the Russians
because screw you go to hell I think
there's a lot of that in the polling now
that is not true with approval rating so
I don't think there are a lot of
Republicans today who are saying you
know I love president Trump but I'm
gonna live the pollsters and say that I
hate President Trump I don't think
there's a lot of that I think there's
more defiance than there is you know an
attempt to purposefully screw up the
polls but I'm not sure how much it
matters because we haven't seen a lot of
head-to-head polls between Trump and
anybody else so today I saw a
head-to-head poll between Trump and Mark
Zuckerberg that showed him like 40% in
Zuckerberg and 40 percent that means
Trump wins reelection right the fact is
that he was running head and neck and
neck with Hillary and then he won so any
Democrat who wins is going to have to be
blowing him out in polls at this time
I'd be curious to see like a Joe Biden
Trump matchup at this point and see how
that would go for him but some of the
polling data for him is not great right
38% of Republicans say his conduct has
been unpresidential rather than fitting
and proper but they don't really care
but word associations with Trump Suites
68% of people say that the Trump streets
are inappropriate 65 percent say they're
insulting 52 percent say dangerous 41
percent say interesting 36 percent say
effective I think that Trump's floor is
about 35 percent 35 36 percent it's a
pretty good floor when floor is a lot
stronger than George HW Bush's floor was
in 2004 2005 2006 right his floor in
2006 was like 20 percent 15 percent and
that is specifically due to the reaction
against the left and the feeling the
left is out to get Trump Sheryl Atkinson
says Trump is basically kryptonite smear
it's very difficult to get him I think
this is essentially correct explain in
your book why you say Trump may be
kryptonite to the smear I call him the
anti smear candidate because every
traditional smear tactic used against
him very effective tactics against other
people kind of bounced off of him you
know the smear was just no good to him
in fact he was able to grab it and
co-opt it and turn it around in most
every case and I argue that if he had
apologized in summer of 2015 when the
first attack that I noticed was after
John McCain called some his followers
crazies and Trump counter-attack by
saying McCain wasn't a war hero
Vietnam they were called the media want
him to get out of the race and apologize
I started airing more of him thinking
the public would hate him if they saw
more of them but the public liked him I
think if he had apologized then he would
never have made it but he did the
opposite of what is intuitive to
politicians but turned out to be the
right thing for him to do for his
followers so I don't think that his base
is going to drop out anytime soon the
question is how much of his basically
turn out to vote and isn't enough for
him to win re-election it's a little
early to talk about reelection not every
day is a battle for re-election for
President Trump but if he let's say he
passed it passes not much can he still
win the answer pretty clearly is yes he
can still win and so you know as long as
his base sticks with him I don't think
his base is going to drop away when they
don't get policy wins I think that
people who think that a bunch of people
are going to drop away because he's not
doing anything I don't think that's
right because what Trump was actually
elected to do is exactly what he's doing
yell at people
Trump was elected to be the avatar of
our anger and he is doing that
successfully and if their policy
failures we're going to place them where
we think the policy experts aren't from
never purported to be a policy expert
it's going to fall on McConnell and Ryan
so I think that's totally deserved no I
think the president has a role and this
is the problem with electing someone who
you expect their job is only going to be
ba and great things and yellow things
but do I think that Trump's bottom is
going to fall out here is he going to go
down into the 20s no he's not he's
already at rock bottom and 36 35 36
percent is not a bad place to be now
it'll be interesting to see if he
swivels to the left in the aftermath of
the Trump careful urine tries to get
some infrastructure stuff done the
Democrats tries to pass more big
government stuff and tries to bring in a
different crowd yeah that is one
strategy for getting to 50 he's going to
need to get closer to 50% if he wants to
win reelection but ironically one of the
best things that might have happened to
him in this entire in this entire cycle
is Michael Lee killing the storm care
bill because imagine if the Trump care
bill actually passed and now Trump owns
what comes next in the health care
system well Trump I think Trump knows
this by the way which is why he's not
fully fulminating over the failure of
Trump care I think Trump knows it would
have been politically poisonous for him
to pass something this unpopular and
then sign it and he'd have that hanging
around his neck for 2020 Michael he
might have just saved Trump's presidency
by killing this bill unfortunately it
also the the Republican failure to kill
Obamacare also demonstrates what what
lackeys
they are so you could easily see a
situation in which Trump wins
re-election after Democrats win the
house in 2018 try to impeach him and the
reaction is so strong that he wins
re-election but you can see Republicans
not being able to get anything done you
know and maybe all we got out of this
was Gorsuch and we'll find out if that's
enough okay so with all of that said
when the rush of fallout continues it is
amazing that the Democrats are really
grasping at straws here they don't need
to the overreach is so great from the
Trump administration the Democrats don't
need to overreach but everyone is
incompetent and everything so for
example there's a Democratic
Representative Mike Quigley he makes one
of most bizarre statements I have ever
heard about this Russia Trump Russia
stuff listen to this statement I think
that there was coordination I think
you're starting to see public evidence
of that coordination not just a meeting
with Trump jr.
but others as well you know Roger stone
suggesting that he had a relationship
with Julian Assange and WikiLeaks and he
knew that mr. Podesta was next in the
barrel but actually a paint digital
operation well I don't want to get into
specifics in terms of the digital
operation or any specifics that that are
not in the public domain at this point
in time I think you're seeing a clear
pattern of people in the Trump campaign
coordinating with Russians and I think
what we're learning with the Trump jr.
meeting is when you meet with any
Russians you're meeting with Russian
intelligence and therefore President
Putin okay so the idea that if you mean
with any Russian ever you're suddenly
meeting with Vladimir Putin is totally
insane and this is why people are
responding with ire to all of this
meanwhile the Trump administration is
actual defense on Trump Russia is not
very good right meaner Sean Spicer
yesterday talking about this is
literally yesterday okay talking about
the Trump jr. meeting with the Russians
here's what he had to say that is quite
often for people who are given
information during the heat of a
campaign to to ask what that is that's
what simply he did the president's made
it clear through his tweet and and there
was nothing as far as we know that would
lead anyone to believe that there was
anything except for discussion about
adoption the Majin ski act okay there
was
results called Magnitsky act but hit but
there was anything except for adoptions
um how about like the entire email
exchange that says it's not about
adoptions how about that like that might
lead you to believe that but again the
democrats are so so crazy that they're
willing to grasp it any straw here and
this is what is driving support for
Trump again it's a lot of reaction and
not a lot of policy and so we're going
to have to ask ourselves do we demand
from President Trump that he gave us
policy or as reactionary stuff enough
maybe it is enough maybe it is enough
but I'm not sure that it's enough for me
I don't think it should be enough for
conservatives because you know I whole
group of people who spend their days
reacting against the left I am one of
those people the president's job should
be partly to do that but it should also
be to push policy that's actually good
okay time for some things I like things
I hate and then we'll deconstruct a
little bit of culture so things that I
like I just began it all so before I do
that you know I want to I want to first
say thank you to our sponsors over at
the u.s. concealed-carry Association so
you are at home it's late at night you
hear somebody rumbling around your front
door and then you see the end of a
crowbar because somebody's try and get
in your house so you go over you're done
safety unlock it you grab your gun they
break in your house and you shoot them
what happens next nobody ever thinks
about what happens after you shoot the
guy right you're the hero of the movie
except for when the police come and
arrest you and then they ask a bunch of
questions and they hold you up in the
legal system for three years and it cost
you tens of thousands of dollars to
defend yourself this is why you need to
go over and sign up with the u.s. CCA
not only they provide complete peace of
mind in an unpredictable world they give
you education training and make sure
that you are legally and financially
protected for after you pull the trigger
so they make sure that you know you are
covered for that situation if you
actually have to do it they tell you
when to pull the trigger and they also
help you after you've pulled the trigger
they are also working on getting more
guns into the hands of law-abiding
Americans so they still have their July
4th promotion running and that is that
you can go over to the website defend my
family now.com defend my family now calm
and you get five chances to win 1776
dollars worth of guns and ammo again
it's defend my family now calm yet 1700s
shot at 1776 dollars worth of guns and
ammo of your choice which is just
awesome you actually have five shots at
winning it when you go over and register
at spend my family now calm you should
anyway just to get the US ECA services
but I mean for the shot at nearly two
thousand dollars worth of
and ammo that seems like a pretty good
deal go over there and register right
now defend my family now calm for your
free shot at that at that guns and ammo
giveaway because that is super cool okay
time for some things I like so now
there's a book called dreamland by Sam
Quinn ona's I heard about this on the
commentary podcast I just started it is
really good it is I think it won the the
Pulitzer it's all about the heroin
epidemic the opioid epidemic that you've
heard so much about it traces the
epidemic where it came from
why it's affecting small towns in a
different way than it's affecting big
cities opioid episode addiction is a
very different thing in many cases then
a typical like cocaine addiction or or
other hard drug addiction the reason for
this is because most opioids are
originally prescribed by dr. right you
go into the doctor you want a painkiller
they give you hydrocodone the next thing
you know you're looking for an oxycontin
and the next thing you know you can't
get down to you're looking at black tar
heroin this happens a lot it happens a
lot we are a country that feels that
pain is something that we should be able
to do away with and so we over prescribe
when it comes to opioids pharmaceutical
companies have an interest in us to over
prescribe and when it comes to opioids
and then it is very difficult to get off
of them I know this because my
grandmother back in the 1970s actually
experienced opioid addiction they put
her on a painkiller she became addicted
to it she thank God she went through
cold turkey withdrawal which is
absolutely brutal my dad had to help
guide her through it was like 13 years
old which is crazy but she was able to
get off of it but opioid the opioid
epidemic is one that actually can be
dealt with in ways that some of the
other epidemics cannot be because you
can stop sometimes you might be able to
stop it at the source in terms of
prescriptions you know forget about
heroin dealing and legalization of drugs
the the prescription of drugs over
prescribed and doctors have to be very
careful in you as a patient should be
very very careful before you started
accepting prescription dosages of
opioids because they are highly highly
addictive okay other things that I like
so for those who missed it over at
Evergreen State College there was this
insane story where a professor named
Brett Weinstein refused to not go to
work on the quote week without white or
day without whites and who's forced to
flee the college after he refused to
participate right okay what Weinstein is
a
real leftist and he spoke informed in
front of the Board of Trustees about
what exactly happened to them pretty
incredible do you know that the college
descended into literal anarchy and that
for days the campus was not under the
control of the state it was under the
control of protesters that there were
assaults
there were batteries there was pressure
not to report crimes to the police
people were by the legal definition I
believe kidnapped and imprisoned that
included faculty members and
administrators others were hunted on the
campus that lawless bands roamed the
campus unimpeded police were physically
and intentionally blocked by protesters
police were cruelly systematically and
personally taunted they were humiliated
and forced to stand down by the
president students that held different
opinions were by the protesters own
analysis stalked harassed and DOX to
meaning that their names pictures and
addresses and phone numbers were
distributed online do you know that
concessions made under intimidation and
threat during the protests are now being
enacted by the college that includes
mandatory bias training for all faculty
this has come about by an agreement
between the faculty being good for this
guy the one remember is a leftist ok
Weinstein is a hardcore leftist and here
he is testifying like a right wing or
because the left is so insane this is
why the hard left is eventually going to
drive everybody into Trump's arms okay
time for some things that I hate
okay thing I hate number one when people
who are not cool try to be cool so one
of the things that I appreciate about
myself because I'm awesome
is that I don't try to be cool okay I
don't try to be cool because I am NOT
cool I'm super nerdy I'm a giant dork
okay the fact is I know I am NOT cool
and therefore I do not try to be hip and
with-it and with the kids because that's
stupid because I think a lot of the
things the kids do our stupid so this
apparently does not hold true for our
congresspeople the Speaker of the House
yesterday came out and said he loves
emojis is he a teenage girl no just no
you know I have you ever seen the shirt
where it shows the evolution of man and
you know it's got the the amoebas it's
got the monkeys and then it goes all the
way up to man well I have a whole thing
about the evolution of language that
basically we went from grunting at each
other to hieroglyphics to short with the
short phrases to full language now we
are going back to short phrases through
text messages and then back to
hieroglyphics through three emojis I
have a deep and abiding hatred for for
over uses emojis and yet here's Paul
Ryan the Speaker of the House talking
about why he loves emojis we text and we
talk every night I call home and to talk
because they don't think of me as an
emoji guy I go crazy on emoji because I
mean I do like seven or eight of these
things because I'll throw those out
there and my kids in my wife I am just
not the emoji type person so they think
so that's why I just overkill on the
emojis in the happy socket music is the
part that really gets me and then it
says happy world emoji day no no go do
your stupid job you stupid people and
stop it with the stupid emojis my
goodness
okay another things that I hate Caitlyn
Jenner whose sole qualification for
running for the Senate is apparently the
Caitlyn Jenner is a dude who thinks that
he is a lady and the rest of the world
is going to humor him in this in this
sad delusion says that he should run for
Senate in California now listen if he
runs for Senate in California as a
Republican I will vote for him you know
he still a dude but I'll vote for him
because he's not a Democrat so fine I
mean this the state is crazy enough I
mean Arnold Schwarzenegger is our
freakin governor and now we have a
corpse walking
our Governor Jerry Brown in actual
living corpse is walking around as the
governor who I don't know where I am
I've been governor since like 1972 but
who oh my heart Oh Governor of
California so if Caitlyn Jenner runs for
Senate I don't know I'll vote for him in
a primary but in a general election it
forced to do so I will do so here's
Caitlyn Jenner saying that he will run
for the Senate because why the hell not
everyone showed got Kid Rock in Michigan
and Caitlyn Jenner in California Arkham
Asylum is now the United States Senate
Al Franken is an actual senator from
Minnesota and president Trump is the
president I don't know what's going on
again we entered the alternative
timeline where Biff was able to actually
bent on 1955 World Series baseball games
and now he married Marty's mother okay
here is Caitlyn Jenner Caitlyn there's a
rumor there's a rumor that you want to
run for the United States Senate in
California did you hear that rumor John
I heard a way how did it get all the way
back to you all the way from teleport a
LeFort yeah I have considered it I like
the political side of it if there's one
thing I work very closely with the group
called American unity fund that their
sole purpose their mission statement is
to get the Republican Party to do a
better job when it comes to all LGBT
issues that's kind of my issue obviously
I'm more on the Tees portion of the LGBT
and I want people to understand that but
the political side of it all always been
very intriguing to me over the next six
months or so I got to find out where I
can do a better job can I do a better
job from the outside kind of work in the
perimeter the political scene being open
to you know talk to anybody or are you
better off from the inside and we are in
the process of determining that and yeah
but I would look for a senatorial run um
no okay so just know again I understand
that nobody has to have any
qualifications these days like being
able to read
legislation or you know have positions
and that fame is a sole qualifier but
this is not a door that I think is great
that it's been opened all right whatever
all right so let's deconstruct a culture
for one second okay so the the news of
the day is that according to BuzzFeed
reporter Jim DeRogatis three sets of
parents are claiming their daughters
have been brainwashed and they're being
held against their will in a cult by R&B
star Robert R Kelly three former members
of the singers inner circle back up such
a council reveal even more disturbing
details of actions allegedly perpetrated
by the singer with a litany of sex
related criminal accusations launched
against them including child porn
charges
is according to Amanda prestige Acoma
over at Daily wire they say the young
women are reportedly being held by Kelly
at properties he owned in Atlanta and
Chicago the reports allege the girls are
initially promised help with their music
careers before Kelly lures them into an
abusive sexual relationship
the singer reportedly videotapes their
sexual encounters forces the girls to
calm daddy and wears only bet and we're
only baggy attire to hide their figures
permits them to communicate via cell
phone with only him and routinely
verbally and physically abuses the
females punishing them for ridiculous
infractions such as laughing at male cab
drivers joked so this story made the
rounds but it didn't turn into a
front-page story can you imagine if this
had been a country star who had done
this I have a feeling that there would
be a lot more ire if it were like Toby
Keith who had done this because it would
actually confirm a lot of left media
bias with regard to right-wing people
right that everybody who's actually
sexist and brutal women and keeping them
in the back room and using them as sex
the hands made tail which is what this
sounds like right The Handmaid's Tale is
it wouldn't be it has to be coming from
the right but our Kelly is a rapper now
what's hilarious about this is that if
you actually listen to a lot of rap
songs which we have done in our in our
deconstructing the culture segments
before the idea of treating women as
garbage is not particularly rare in in
rap culture it's not a particularly
respectful medium toward women and their
autonomy so I'm not sure that we should
be super shocked by anything our Kelly
is doing it's also not unique to rap
culture right it's in Hollywood the
casting couch has been a thing forever
the idea that directors use their sexual
leverage over willing starlets in order
to get in bed with them and then
sometimes abuse them right I mean that
sort of thing has been going on in
Hollywood for years
two things worth noting here one is that
less cultures which is Hollywood and the
rap culture left cultures that
supposedly are offering quality when it
comes to their actual activity very
often or not and number two the the
quest for fame in our culture has become
so egregious and so negative that people
are putting themselves into dangerous
situations but they wouldn't otherwise
because they want Fame okay Fame is not
all that it is cracked up to be because
the fact is that even once you are
famous what you actually need is a is a
place to be safe and away from the fame
so you know I think that it is a I think
that it is sad that we as a culture have
decided to to value Fame over over
genuine value as a human being that that
is happening everywhere from politics to
pop culture and I don't think it's going
to change anytime soon okay so we will
be back tomorrow and when we do come
back we will have updates on Trump care
hopefully president Trump will have an
alternative plan who wants to pursue so
that I can say nice things about him
tomorrow that would be great I am Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]